I mean this happens a lot this is
extraordinary this story yeah so in
China the trick is there's two aspects
of it have a Chinese name and an English
name the Chinese name Gao Xiang same one
that Goldman Sachs uses a fairly generic
word that means like top the victory
fine but their own website which sadly
isn't available right now does say
Goldman Sachs spells at the same way the
fonts pretty similar in brackets
shenzhen and when i called up and said
hey ru goldman sachs i said it we're
goldman sachs shen jen i said are you
affiliated no no no gree we're you know
it's kind of just enjoying a bit of the
glow there so in China the trademark
issue is a hard one they're not goldman
sachs isn't the only person are only
company facing a problem Michael Jordan
famously lost the case against the
sportswear company where the Chinese
name is the Chinese version of his name
showed on Apple autumn had problems with
another company the fake apple stools de
Knable and fake apple stores there's the
ipad name so trademark law in china is
generally kind of a tricky thing and
other banks in china there's a famous
guy got his family to stop staff a fake
bank of a bank branch bank of
communications or construction i forget
which so not the first time okay i mean
it company i go massage does
reputational damage they're not gonna
take this lighting really lying down I
don't know they didn't seem too stressed
out about it um when I spoke to them so
who knows now that it gets bigger it
might be they know about it no they had
they hadn't heard about this before and
I don't know you know this this
financial leasing company claims to be
pretty big they have some this story
came with like because of a casino union
in the States kind of making allegations
they have some shady connections so who
knows if they'll look further into it
talking about that they're not you know
talking about how came to light so what
was the mechanism exactly so there's a
casino union states and they've been
pushing for tighter regulation in
scrutiny over the junket operations in
Macau basically the guys who bankroll
high Chinese rollers and there's a lot
of allegations of connections the money
laundering triads etc and so they've
been writing letters to the chinese
antique
ruption authorities sort of open letters
and it was a you know in this letter
they mentioned here are some
institutions you take a look at
including this goldman sachs which we
they say also isn't affiliated with
goldman sachs the one we famously know
but they say you have to take a look at
it looks like it might be facilitating
some dodgy business at best